Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, this
is going to be a breakdown of all that awesome
new arrow footage.
They’re calling it the High Speed Chase
promo, but really it was all about showing
off some of the secondary characters like
Malcolm Merlyn, Thea, Ray Palmer and Vertigo.
Some of the footage was repeated from the
earlier trailer so I’m just going to focus
on the new stuff.
Also big news, Stephen Amell just revealed
they cast Matt Noble as Ra’s Al Ghul, so
I’ll talk about that after the trailer stuff.
Starting with said high speed chase.
Team Arrow has pretty much been on a winning
streak since they took down Slade.
But here’s the funny part, Felicity as you
can see is working at a Tech village.
Anyone who watched Chuck will enjoy this.
If you didn’t, Brandon Routh’s character
played an evil secret agent.
Watch it, you’ll have some fun.
It’s on Netflix.
Felicity of course being the Chuck character.
Remember, the Arrow Cave was destroyed in
the finale and Oliver has no money.
Even though it looks like they rebuilt it
somehow.
So it looks like she’s working there as
a day job and just hijacking the equipment
to help Oliver with his extracurricular activities.
The other big tease is them dating.
Since the premiere is when this big Olicity
date goes down, I’m guessing all of these
scenes in the trailer are from that first
episode.
They haven’t been dating all summer, he
just asks her out like was saw in the first
trailer.
So this is just what happens later that night.
I don’t think I know what Felicity’s favorite
food is, besides Pizza.
Everyone’s favorite food is pizza.
The diggle voice over just explains they’ve
been kicking ass and reducing the crime level
to near zero.
The title of the premiere is “The Calm”,
which means a lot of things, both that crime
is almost gone, and Calm before
the storm.
Speaking of storm, here’s a new shot of
peter stormare.
It shows a finished visual effect of what
he’ll look like when people are tripping
on Vertigo.
I like that they updated this to look even
crazier.
I wonder if they worked the title of the episode
after casting peter stormare, so they could
say the calm before the stormare.
Usually that’s not the way it happens.
It’s probably just a coincidence.
But I like thinking all the writers are laughing
and writing jokes like that.
I love that they follow up new bad guy with
new good guy Ray Palmer.
He’s the Atom, so we know he’s good, and
he’ll join team arrow at some point.
But when we first meet him, he’ll be yoinking
Oliver’s company and possibly yoinking felicity.
So he and Oliver will have a really awkward
relationship until they have their bro moment.
Their Broment. which I’m sure will have
something to do with Peter Stormare.
His scene is super quick, but one of the big
things it shows us is how funny season 3 is
going to be.
Stephen Amell for example said that he smiled
more in the first episode than he had in all
of seasons 1 and 2 combined.
The whole tone of the show is lightening up
a bit and I think it’s going to make it
a lot more fun to watch.
There’s this big thing going on at DC’s
Film unit where character’s aren’t allowed
to be super funny.
Like in Batman vs Superman.
Thankfully that is not the case for DC TV
Shows.
Adding Brandon Routh as a foil for Stephen
Amell gives so many opportunities for Oliver
to react.
Usually it’s Felicity reacting to him doing
things, but now the power dynamic is shifting
a little.
Ray Palmer owns a tech company that buys a
majority stake in Queen Industries.
So Brandon Routh is now Stephen Amell’s
boss.
But not in the toxic and kind of sexual way
Summer Glau was last year.
I’m sure tumblr will have some fun with
the Oliver/Summer Glau/Brandon Routh gifsets
though.
Everybody watch out for those.
The new attitude tag again seems mostly about
the secondary characters stepping up.
I keep shipping Laurel as kind of a Kate Spencer
Manhunter analog this year, that’s not exactly
what’s happening.
Really she’s just going to start taking
a page from Oliver’s book and get more hands
on with justice.
Roy of course is in full on sidekick mode.
Which is really cool.
He was kind of a rage zombie for most of last
year.
The other new footage I’m really excited
about is Thea in training.
As much as I want her to become Artemis, I
think the show will be more ambiguous about
her identity and she’ll just be a more punchy
version of thea.
No idea where all this training is happening,
but I’m guessing it’s not in starling
city.
I’m really happy for Willa Holland though.
One of the things I’m most looking forward
too is her kicking Roy’s butt a little.
Merlyn finally appears too.
I was bummed he hadn’t been in any of the
trailers yet but now it seems like he’s
hijacking a truck in this shot.
We still don’t know a lot about what his
arc is going to be in season 3.
Or how it will relate to Team Arrow.
I think of Merlyn as a neutral third party
that will play nice or be bad as a means to
get what he wants.
So fingers crossed that he and Oliver get
to team up against Ra’s Al Ghul before the
finale.
There will be plenty of them beating the crap
out of each other before that though.
The Olicity Date Line: Things You don’t
know about me is just about his time in Hong
Kong.
That will probably be what sets off the new
flashback sequences.
The only confusing part of the trailer is
Oliver and Roy not in costume fighting military
dudes.
Either this happens on an undercover mission
or it’s part of the big overarching plot.
Like these military people are mercenaries
working for Count Vertigo.
And these shipping containers are all his
drugs.
But you totally saw it right, Oliver shot
and killed them.
Which is a big left turn from his big ‘not
killing people’ thing in season 2.
Actually yes, this quiver on roy’s back
makes me think this was an undercover mission.
Episode 1 premieres Wednesday October 8th
at 8PM Eastern Time.
If you’re international just adjust based
on time zone.
I know in the UK supposedly you guys get episodes
a little later.
So just adjust your premiere based on the
time between the season 2 US premiere and
when you got Season 2 Episode 1.
It’ll basically be the same as last year.
The Flash is also premiering Tuesday the 7th.
I’m doing videos for all the DC TV Shows,
there
are 4 of them.
so be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Now Ra’s Al Ghul casting.
This is the other big bomb they dropped.
Stephen Amell was the one who first announced
it on his twitter.
Matt Nable is who they picked.
He’s another aussie, which I think is an
awesome coincidence given Manu Bennett being
the big bad last year.
Technically Manu was born in New Zealand so
he’s a kiwi, but you get the idea.
Just imagine the meta thing going on where
Slade is secretly related to Ra’s Al Ghul.
That’s not true in the comics, but it’s
another point of conversation for tumblr to
pick up and run with.
Nable you probably remember from Riddick,
the third chronicles of riddick movie.
From a couple years ago.
Here’s a quick interview clip with him just
so you can get an idea for what he sounds
like.
(clip)
He’ll probably adjust his speech pattern
to suit the Ra’s Al Ghul character, but
I can’t wait to see him unleash on Starling.
Lots of questions as to why he’s coming
to starling although Malcolm Merlyn, Talia
al Ghul, Black Canary and Vertigo are all
possible reasons.
I’m interested to see if Brandon Routh’s
character has any ties to him.
At least within the world of the show.
In the comics, the Atom doesn’t interact
with Ra’s Al Ghul.
But Arrow has done a good job linking all
of the guest character stories by the finale
each year.
We can talk more about possible connections
in future bonus videos but we are now within
the 4 week window of the premiere.
So let me know what kind of Arrow/Flash/Constantine
etcetera bonus videos you want to see me do.
When we get to that week before the premiere,
I’ll be doing extra bonus videos for everything
all the shows.
Since there’s so many shows I want to do
videos for I’m still trying to figure out
my video schedule for October.
So I’ll probably post a separate video explaining
that once it’s ready.
In the meantime, learn all about Ra’s Al
Ghul here and click here for my Villains Power
Ranking.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!